[Musique]
des paysages à couper le souffle à 3000
m d'altitude
cette année il a beaucoup plu de quoi
rendre l'accès à ces zones compliqué
[Musique]
s'ils attaquent à une api s'il y a des
gros cailloux ne t'arrête pas c'est
l'espace illégal continue sur ce rythme
oui ça se mérite reste toujours la même
vitesse il te plaisent toujours manqué
stade frédéric va rencontrer pour la
première fois les petits cultivateurs de
maïs qu'il importe à paris en chemin il
s'arrête devant une des dernières
récoltes de la saison plus qu'un champ
un tableau impressionniste un voyage
dans le temps
[Musique]
on est bien en 2018 et il ya encore des
endroits sur cette planète
on continue à faire de la qualité
simplement avec la graine et la main de
l'homme
quelques kilomètres plus tard frédéric
arrive à destination
ici la récolte est terminée depuis une
semaine c'est le temps du séchage
[Musique]
il
c'est très calme ici travailler dans le
calme sandrine il ya pas un bruit sur
cette petite parcelle plusieurs familles
égrène les épis de maïs ici le travail
est rémunéré au poids existe il existe
des champs plus petits que ceux là oui
plus petits hameaux beaucoup plus petit
moi c'est ce que je te disais hier
celui-ci est presque le plus grand de la
zone les autres agriculteurs ont des
chants beaucoup plus petit parce qu'en
france là où on sème le maïs ce ne sont
pas des endroits montagneux ce sont des
chants plat est immense où il ya des
machines qui ramassent tout c'est une
production industrielle dans ce champ où
ils fredo cultive principalement du maïs
blanc à gros grain et du maïs orange est
plus petit de quoi donner des idées à
frédéric quelle belle couleur c'est du
mana il peut gonfler comme du pop corn
s'était dit sinapi vous connaîtrez celui
là frédéric non j'avais jamais vu ce vin
isla j'avais vu le résultat final donc
le snack et tout ça me disait toujours
c'est du maillot jaune du maillot jaune
du maillot jaune mais en fait c'est pas
du tout le maïs jaune que j'imaginais
voilà donc j'en découvre encore une
nouvelle variété de maïs est vraiment
laid tellement belle pendant envie
d'avoir tout de suite celui là je le
ramène venir en france
c'est ce que je te disais on importe de
trois variétés mais il y en a plein en
fait
moi je croyais que les français ne
manger que du maïs en boîte chez ce
paysan pas de maïs en boîte bien sûr pas
de traitement chimique non plus tout est
bio j'ai mon troupeau pour mettre de
l'engrais bio sur ma terre et à la
latière l'irrigation bien d'un lac qui
se situe à 4800 mètres au dessus du
niveau de la mer c'est un bassin le
bassin wassaï maillot et c'est donc de
l'eau pure non contaminé dos avoisine
pierre la décontamination à la
filtration naturelle c'est ça on est des
privilégiés
on sait que c'est un privilège
d'irriguer avec une eau qui n'est pas
pollué un cercle agricole vertueux mais
aujourd'hui menacée en cause le
dérèglement climatique
actuellement on a des problèmes et c'est
lié au climat car il ne devrait pas
pleuvoir en cette saison on est en hiver
et il pleut c'est problématique pour
nous comme vous voyez nous devons tout
couvrir avec des bâches plastiques et de
l'est s'il te plaît
tu t'es pas possible
la pluie abîme le mail pour une première
visite et bien on s'est mis au travail
directement oui aux et mouillez vous
allez jusqu'au bout pour vous
après cusco et les andes frédéric fait
escale à lima la capitale
[Musique]
oui
avant de continuer sa prospection de
nouveaux produits
frédéric s'accordent une pause
gastronomique
qu'elle savait pourquoi salir cible
parce que ça ne l'est
vous devez avoir une astuce non c'est
parce que c'est une très belle dame qui
les a fait ça c'est le la principale qui
est préparé à base de maïs
ça s'appelle des tamales et yen à
différentes recettes voilà il peut y en
avoir qui sont douces donc les gens ont
su créer d'autres légèrement pimentée
donc c'est la base du maïs heures en
farine que l'on assaisonner relevé un
peu avec un peu de piment là vous le
voyez ici ça c'est le piment très fort
mais énormément c'est un piment doux qui
donne cette couleur qui s'appelle le
piment banca et ça c'est quoi cette
feuille c'est de la feuille de bananier
et l'autre c'est la feuille de maïs
choclo c'est quoi la différence c'est la
même préparation mais cela change le
goût et certaines personnes préfèrent
celui à base de chaux au préau et
d'autres avec la feuille de banane et je
le trouve parfait parce que parfois ils
sont trop sec
ah oui et là on peut pas les manger il
faut mettre la sauce criolla assez
savoureux patron sec parce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui mettent ça avec de la sauce
très piquante
du coup ça perd de sa saveur ça devient
est mangeable
je peux vous dire que ça vaut le coup de
faire 12 heures d'avion pour venir
goûter sa wii 12 heures assis dans un
avion à mais au moins vous ramènerez des
très bonnes choses chez vous
des bonnes choses frédéric vasse vont
chercher au grand marché de santa anita
le rungis locale
ici on trouve de tout et en particulier
du maïs
celui ci vient de tshing as lots de
chavin oui entre chaque région on va
avoir en plus des saveurs différentes ça
s'utilise en infusion on peut aussi en
faire une infusion
bien sûr c'est très bon et c'est aussi
bon pour la santé
c'est un très bon anti inflammatoire
très intéressant pour les reins pour la
plante
on s'imagine pas du tout ses vertus
médicinales à st juste de l'apprendre ce
sont leurs propres médecins médecine
leurs nombreux médicaments dans la
montagne ils ont pas de médicaments fait
ce qu'ils mangent et soigne on habitué
des lieux et des produits locaux
frédéric continue pourtant d'enrichir
ses connaissances à chacune de ses
visites et de toutes les variétés de
maïs c'est le fameux maïs violer le plus
intéressant du point de vue de la santé
il ne fait pas de mauvaise publicité à
mon maïs d'accord
non non non non vous inquiétez pas et
vous demander uniquement du maïs violet
j'ai vendu du maïs violet toute ma vie
que du viol et oui toujours du maïs
violet si tu regarde mon colon tu verras
que j'ai aucun problème
le maïs violet serait un super aliments
auxquels on prête ici toutes les vertus
c'est l'ingénieur venez s'il vous plaît
ingénieux oui un ingénieur il sait tout
du maïs lui la qualité principale du
maïs c'est l'anti oxia nine
c'est un antioxydant bon pour la santé
les grains de sommeil violet permettent
de perdre du poids il peut être
conseillé pour les personnes souffrant
d'obésité
aussi je ne savais pas
la pigmentation c'est bon pour
l'hémoglobine
c'est ici que se trouvent les qualités
du maïs violer le coeur du maïs
concentre lentilles aux gamines
comme cette pulpe du grain c'est le
meilleur qui puisse exister
on trouve ce maïs en bolivie et en
colombie comment vinet aussi cultivé
mais il n'a pas autant dans tes aussi à
nîmes que le nôtre cela s'apprend le
râble et vous le vendez aussi bien sûr
aucun mentalement collomb c'est ça qui
donne on le fait bouillir dans l'eau
jusqu'à obtenir le plus de couleurs
possibles
c'est avec ça qu'on fait la boisson
shichahai on fait aussi de la bière avec
la première bière péruvienne à base de
maïs violer je la créativité du
péruvienne va jusqu à ces niveaux là
incroyable ça sent bon
[Musique]
vous aimez tellement le maïs viol et que
même votre veste de cette couleur et
vous aussi
oui moi aussi je lai dans le coeur à
quai alors voilà ma carte avec les corps
de l'année mon téléphone mon adresse
mail et vous pouvez me contacter aussi
sur facebook
est-ce que vous avez une casse oui ça
c'est la mienne et celle de ma collègue
et avec ça tu vas pouvoir me trouver et
ça c'est mon numéro de téléphone très
bien
c'est fantastique merci beaucoup